Thanks again, Dean. Let's cut up the exploration Dean just
described. First, we should use the set seed function to
make this reproducible. Running this one line of code will
also allow you to see the same households in my
explorations, if you use the same seed number. Now, let's
sample 16 of the households from our yogurt data set,
from yogurt ID. Notice that I'm sampling from the levels
because those are all of the different households that I have.
I'll run the code for the sample ID's. And then, I'll
print out the sample ID's. There's the 16 of them. Now
we can plot each purchase occasion for each of the households
that we sampled. We have the time of the purchase, the
price per item of the yogurt, and the number of items.
Here, I'm using the size parameter to add more detail to
my plot. I'm passing at the all purchases variable, so that
way I can consider the number of items in terms of size
of the point on the plot. So, before I run this
code, I want you to take a minute to think about
what type of plot this code will produce. You maybe want
to pause for a moment and give yourself some time to
think. Now you might also notice this new syntax here. This
percent in percent sign. This just tells us to loop over
the IDs, so that when we go through and create a
panel plot, for each ID of our households. And here's the plot.
Notice how we get panels for each of the households
that we had in our sample. From these plots, we
can see the variation and how often each household buys
yogurt. Here, a lot and here, not to much. And
it seems that some household purchases more quantities than others
with these larger circles indicating not here. For most of
the households, the price of yogurt holds steady, or tends
to increase over time. Now, there are, of course, some exceptions,
like in this household and in this household, and even here,
we might think that the household is using coupons to drive the
price down. Now, we don't have the coupon data to associate with
this buying data, but you could see how that information could be
paired to this data to better understand the consumer behavior. So
now, let's have you do something similar. Your task is to create
a similar plot and provide your own insights for another set of
16 houses. I like you to create a discussion post that includes
your seed number and the title and in the post, you can include an image of your
plot and any observations that you make. You may
want to try this for a few households to
get a better feel for the data and the
plot. There won't be any solution video here, so
we'd love to hear from you all and see
you all discuss what's going on in the discussions.